the following reaction is brought to you
by greg saw reject nation
i i can't even attempt to hide my
excitement right now see when i woke
it's john
what's up real rejects you know the deal
greg's out of town
here we go i've been looking forward to
this trailer all day long
i thought when i woke up this morning
this would be the first thing that i
would cover before moving on to prepping
a few things for patreon was a certain
movie review
the name of which i cannot say i thought
this would be the first thing i would be
covering today it's the last thing for
youtube i'll be covering today but
actually
uh it's perfect i'm gonna sit back and
enjoy myself because if you've caught us
talking about
the movies that have been pushed back in
light of recent events the most
anticipated
one for me and i think at least toward
the top of greg's anticipated list has
been
this movie spiral uh what is it called
the
from the book of saul i love the current
time we live in because now everyone's
really
trying to find new ways of calling
something a cinematic universe without
calling it a cinematic universe anyway
this is chris rock's
saw joint along with darren balzman long
time saw series director i'm a big saw
fan
i'm a big horror fan and i am really
excited to see what this group comes up
with so let's check this trailer
out
oh yeah if you could like and subscribe
and click the notification bell and all
that stuff
very much appreciated
[Music]
[Music]
this package in
[Music]
get everybody out here
play me classic
classic jigsaw hello detective banks
do you know where your officers are
wait i thought that jigsaw killer was
dead he is
he's never dead
they're hours not days how can i catch
this guy if there's nobody on the bus
you can't do this alone it is her what's
her name she's on riverdale right now
personal was the last time you saw your
father
oh damn
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
he could be anyone we're gonna tear this
city apart
whoa whoa
when was the last time you fire your
father
okay interesting
interesting okay oh man i just i just
have so many thoughts
i'm gonna do my best to keep this brief
though this looks like
the ideal exploitation movie if that
makes sense because what you have here
is something that certainly looks like
it's doing its best to return
saw to the element that kind of gets
overlooked i feel like when
a lot of people think about saw you know
you think about the traps and the
torture and the horror and the you know
music video
ghost trail freak out shots and stuff
but you don't think as much about the
fact that you know especially
at the roots and especially with like
the first saw it is
also a police procedural movie and most
of the movies
have something to do with either the
police
involved in the investigation no matter
how tangentially across the force that
gets
or you know other people in law
enforcement there's an element of that
procedural
genre at work here and so what i
appreciate about this
is that it looks like it's certainly
giving a lot more credence
to the cop side of the story this looks
like it wants to be borrowing from a lot
of you know police
crime thrillers i think the obvious pull
is seven
especially with you know the nature of a
saw movie anyway
already having kind of borrowed
influence from seven but i like
the way that they're transcribing that
here especially with
all these dutch angles really fluid
shots and stuff like that they're giving
the cinematography
especially a more upscaled vibe and
aesthetic you know not
quite as grungy all of the time if that
makes sense
and yeah the fact that you have sam
jackson ostensibly as chris rock's dad
in this
it's interesting because i could i can
feel it going either way it's like to a
degree it's a saw movie
and we don't need this to be like the
most serious freaking drama about these
two cops but at the same time
i appreciate that they're going there
and that everyone seems that invested
you know
because like there is a meme quality you
see sam jackson in a trap at the end and
like that's the number one celebrity you
would probably want to see
mouth off against jigsaw shouts out also
to the new jigsaw tape voice i thought
that was pretty cool sounding too with
this sort of
techno garbled corroded filtration
rather than just slowing it down like on
the tapes it sounds pretty eerie and so
like there is yeah an inherent
meme quality to that you see him in the
trap at the end in that moment i was
actually caught up in it and i was like
oh damn you know like that actually
looks kind of scary but also like you
know he's gonna at least
yell a little bit at whoever jigsaw is
this time and i feel like they have to
be aware of that in casting samuel l
jackson at all in a movie like this but
even so i i like that both he and chris
rock and everybody involved appears to
really be invested in this and seems to
be giving it their all in terms of
performances i mean the dialogue in this
trailer
is all pretty writ large just to kind of
give you the beats so i'm hoping that
the script itself
gives enough credence to these
characters to
you know not make it a character study
necessarily but like dr gordon
and adam in the first movie and even
some of the auxiliary characters moving
forward are memorable characters
and you want enough of that here and i
feel like especially with the just
amount of investment chris rock seems to
have in this
project and how again seriously he
appears to be taking this
i'm hoping that that combines with the
pulp and
schlock that we know and love and expect
from saw and
going to that end this looks interesting
to me because again and i can already
hear
the sort of like keep your politics out
of my torture
but at the same time i think it's an
interesting take
because you know you've got the pig
puppet here and it seems like cops are
specifically being targeted in this
movie it seems like the motivation
of the killer in this story whether it
be a copycat or whether it be revealed
this is taking place
like 100 years ago and jigsaw was
already alive and he time traveled back
there or whatever
whatever justification that ties this
all into being a saw movie it looked
really updated in that sense it's like
you have a puppet element but it's a
little more grounded to
this take on the story in this setting
and even the thing with the pig puppet
it's like
pig masks and the you know pig figure
has always been a part of saw since the
very beginning
so to take a motif that's already
existed and then apply
relevance to it like that is actually
something that's pretty clever to me
about this
the sam jackson trap i couldn't exactly
tell what that was going to become but
it certainly looks like something a bit
elaborate but you also have like earlier
on this guy
strung up in the subway tunnel and if
anything can be
said about this trailer it seems like
they are kind of keeping the torture
aspects closer to the vest
not leading with that which i actually
do appreciate because again
i think to rebrand slightly what they're
doing with song to
establish this is a new chapter and a
new iteration of this moving forward and
it's got a semi
different authorship like like that's
the cool thing that i i
like that they're honing in on this is a
very specific story and it's interesting
that it's you know starring like
two black cops in a situation that seems
like it's very much going to want to
dissect
the ills at work within the police
system in general again
this looks like a solid exploitation
movie to me if you go by the metric that
you have all the exploitable elements
that we love
you have actors who are willing to take
that stuff seriously and
i think a lot of the time you know no
matter how silly or wacky an
exploitation movie can get
sometimes it seems very evident that
they are at least trying to use all this
madness as a means of
discussing or touching upon a relevant
topic and more so than
perhaps any other saw movie beyond the
general moral implications
this seems like it wants to actually be
a bit more about
something than your average saw movie
shouts out to saw six though
because jigsaw is all about sort of
dissecting people's
motivations and decisions it seems like
a pretty natural pivot actually to like
apply a lot of the themes and
confrontations of saw that usually go to
an individual towards instead an
organization or something like that
maybe i'm reading way too far into this
but i like i i like the prospect you
know
it seems like a very natural pivot to
keep saw going in a way that is
interesting fresh but they can also
easily give you all the [ __ ] that you
want
and yeah to that end i like that they
didn't go overboard with showing us
every trap i want to be surprised by
some of these traps
it does look like it still has all the
grit and menace that you want from a
song
movie while at the same time showing
some growth to me at least from
uh director daryn lynn bausman just
because again it looks like they're
taking the saw aesthetic
and the spirit brothers did this to a
degree with jigsaw but even
more so here making it even more
cinematic a bit more
steady but finding new ways of infusing
that
tension and motion that the visuals of
saw have always had
not to mention some pretty cool looking
lighting which you know i think any saw
fan would would tell you it's kind of
nice to see saw not looking all
brownish green i'm really excited for
this still i can see
a way in which this could either end up
cheesy or overly serious
i'm really hoping they mean somewhere in
the middle but either way
i i'm i'm a i'm grinning at you and
stuttering i'm a happy saw man right now
so leave me your thoughts down below are
you guys excited about this what do you
hope to see
from this and uh yeah we'll hit you on
the next one much love thanks for
joining me today thanks for all the love
in the comments today
and i'll see you for whatever's next
[Music]
cheers